Hikaru so many hours so many games spent
in the presence of this worthy opponent
Wesley so sum up your feelings right now
after this incredible match yeah I mean
it was it's crazy I think this match I
mean frankly the way that I look at it
is really came down to who won that
first match on the Champions bracket in
terms of who who's likely going to win I
mean we're so evenly matched um you know
Wesley won yesterday I won today I mean
I would I would say that I think
actually today Wesley was clearly the
better player I was not very sharp um
even though maybe the games don't look
so bad my calculation was horrible
especially in this uh first 10 minute
game this third game we played today I
mean I thought it was just much better
and the next thing I know I'm just like
losing I mean I don't know if I'm
actually losing but I'm much worse in a
night end game
um and so I think my calculation wasn't
great I think Wesley was just better but
fortunately the final game I had this
little little silly idea with Knight A4
and you know I was kind of hoping Wesley
would make a blunder because after
playing so many games it's nice to you
know have a simple simple win there so
it's tough
um but I mean I think either of us could
have won it just ended up being me
though at the end of the day you surely
wanted to end uh the matches and the
championship yesterday unfortunately for
you you weren't able to do so what did
you tell yourself at night trying to get
ready for this matchup
um well I mean I was I was very very
upset with myself uh without specifying
there's there's some other stuff going
on that's significantly bigger than this
tournament that I'll be announcing in
the very near future that I've been
dealing with throughout the event
um so I was pretty upset because if I
had the free day today I could have
taken care of some other stuff
um but but really it's just sort of I
had to reset because coming into this
tournament I had one goal which is
basically you know don't make a fool of
myself and don't lose like 10 or 15
rating points um In classical that was
my only goal I know a lot of people
think that I'm just like showboating or
making stuff up but that was really the
only goal I had in mind and so you know
when I looked looked at yesterday having
lost that match I accomplished the first
goal which was not to lose a ton of
points and then it's sort of if you
could have told me I'd be playing a
tiebreaker against Wesley for for all
the marbles um today I would be happy
with that and so that's really just the
attitude I had but even beyond that I
mean last night you know I actually
didn't really look at chess I kind of I
went I didn't do a recap I didn't look
at chess I went out had some beers
played some pool and uh just forgot
about everything and it seemed to work
out so you just I just tried to get past
as quickly as I could it definitely did
now let's talk about this final moment
in this game you played this move Knight
to E5
did you think that he could ever touch
that pawn on D2 in your while no no no I
mean I I saw that it was just a blunder
so Rook D1 Knight C4 instantly but the
thing is it's weird because before the
and this is one of the dangers of using
computers if you don't have all day is
this Knight A4 move which I played on
move number nine I deviated from the
earlier game with this whole work C1
Knight A4
um I had looked at quite a few different
moves here that were interesting like
Queen A5 and B6 and other things and
then as Wesley was thinking for like a
minute here I'm like well why can't I
just take on E3 and play B6 like he did
in the game so I mean it's like I got
the time Edge but then when he did this
I'm like well what am I doing I mean I
guess I should have taken with a d-pawn
but after playing for so long it's like
why do I want to play one of these end
games I mean it's just I I felt like I
should take my chances
um I don't think what I did was great I
think I think for Wesley he just uh
he just missed well we both miss it of
course but after in in these positions
where I go like
um where I go Knight C3 I think he is
Knight E7 here at some point maybe not
right away but I thought he had 97 and
Knight G6 because the way that I felt
about the position is the only plan I
had was put like Knight H4 Knight F5 or
like 95 95 it feels like I should have
something but if black gets those two
nights on F6 and G6 I don't even know I
mean where's my Center play I can't
really play D4 he's like I can't go E4
so I don't know if you've done this I
think there's a good chance Wesley would
have been the winner actually but
fortunately he played Knight before I
got 95 and then when he was singing for
a while and like right before he played
smooth I think he he like looked up and
looked at me and that's when I was like
I had a feeling he was actually going to
play play Queen takes D2
um and I mean after a long day it's I
mean it's a tragedy for the match on
this way of course but it's you know
it's what it is long tournament uh long
day as well at the office guys join the
conversation really I I just have to say
uh congratulations uh I thought you just
played terrific throughout you're very
very deserving winner winner I I know
you call yourself an amateur Hikaru but
you're beating the best Pros that
America could put up against you yeah I
mean it's it's like um it's funny
because I never like if you go back even
like three years I mean I never do this
but actually when I've won some of these
matches like you know I like when I beat
Wesley here I said sorry because I mean
obviously for him winning this term
would mean a lot more than it means
means for me and I mean not trying to
diminish it in any way but I mean I do
feel bad on some level because like I'm
just here trying not to make a fool of
myself and and then I find a way to win
so
yeah I mean it's it's not going to
change anything though let's put it that
way I know some people think that it
might change I might have some Grand
Ambitions I'll play some tournaments
maybe I'll qualify for the candidates
maybe I won't who cares
so what actually is next for you Hikari
yeah so I mean also you know another
thing I have to say is I mean I have to
give a lot of credit to Wesley because
playing like eight days in a row was was
very hard well I mean I know I had the
one rest they were playing like eight
days in a rows very hard but Wesley to
play I think nine days in a row if I'm
not mistaken so you play every day here
I think he played in Germany played the
Armageddon he played the previous
classical then he played Tata steel so I
mean Wesley's been playing non-stop for
two or three months now and I mean
considering considering how tired I'm
sure he had to be his play was really
really good so I mean a lot a lot of
props uh to Wesley for that of course
for for all of us we now have the great
joy of going and playing this uh chess
Champions Tour event in like four days
or something I don't know it's very very
soon
um so I'll be playing that and then
after that I think finally things slowed
down and I have this event in Norway
Norway chess which will be at the end of
May maybe there was a Champions Tour
event before that but that's what I have
coming up so it'll be exciting one final
question Wesley did mention yesterday
that you stream 24 7 and yet you still
play at the Elite level how do you do it
how do I do it I mean it's very
difficult I think you know I think one
of the the most important things is that
because I'm not studying every day I'm
not playing all these tournaments it's
not as much of a grind I think when you
go from tournament to tournament and you
play the same players like say you know
say in four days I have to play Wesley
well I mean maybe maybe I will actually
in this in this chess Champions Tour
event but when you have to play the same
players you look at these same openings
over and over and over again for for
weeks if not months on end I think that
chess isn't so fresh you start to get
like bored you start to get annoyed I
mean there are a lot of different
emotions that you have and so for me I
think I'm able to sort of look at it as
like trying to play interesting chess
trying to have some fun and really
enjoying because I know that I'm not
going to get an opportunity anytime soon
to play play play over the board chess
so that's just the mindset I have I mean
it seems to work for me
um but you know also beyond that I think
it's just that I am sort of playing with
house money all the time and um I'm just
just trying to come with ideas trying to
surprise my opponents I think there's a
lot more on the line for them there's
much more pressure than there is for me
so I just find a way to make it work but
it's but you know it's not easy it's not
easy at all congratulations you are the
2023 American Cup champion thank you
guys